[Music]
cherry is the name of the next film by
the russo brothers who directed avengers
end game
after several engagements in various mcu
movies and the most successful movies of
all times
they now dedicate themselves to project
of their heart the content of cherry is
about nico walker a former soldier who
became a bank robber afterwards and
processes
experience a novel called cherry a
central theme is the post-traumatic
stress disorder of the young walker who
gets into money troubles due to his
resulting opioid addiction
the russo brothers were so enthusiastic
about this story that they used their
own money to secure the rights in a
bitter contest with the other major
interested parties
in tom holland they've also found an old
acquaintance for the role of nico walker
with kiara bravo and nicole forrester
also involved by the way apple tv plus
has secured the streaming rights where
the film is scheduled to release on
march 12
2021 in addition a cinema release is
planned for february 26th
but how exactly this will be handled
outside the usa
is not yet clear
[Music]
you